foreign
Idaho still do not have a suspect in the
murders of four students at the
University of Idaho stabbed to death in
their own home now they have cleared
some people of wrongdoing including
someone who drove two of the victims
home that night and the person who
called 9-1-1
but as Christina raffini reports they
are now widening their investigation to
make sure that the killer or Killers do
not get away
the Flyers went up on Sunday hastily
taped to businesses cafes even Street
pools asking the public for help
someone's murdered child in our
community is everyone's murder child in
our community Vanessa stirring has seven
kids including one who's a student at
the University of Idaho I know that
there's a monster out there that is
capable of doing this
but it's hard to wrap my head around at
a press conference Sunday Moscow police
disclosed a new fact the 9-1-1 call was
made from one of the surviving roommates
phones but not by the roommate at the
time of the call there were other people
in the house
honestly I'm not quite sure at this time
police say the victims Kaylee Gonzalez
Madison mojen Zanna kernodle and Ethan
Chapin were likely asleep when they were
attacked CBS News has confirmed some of
them were killed in their beds on the
second and third floors police say they
were stabbed multiple times by a large
military-style knife some of the victims
had defensive wounds the two roommates
who were home at the time of the attack
but unharmed are not considered suspects
we're not getting any answers and we're
not going to settle for that Olivia
Stevenson says her sister Kaylee and her
friends did everything right to stay
safe but it wasn't enough they went out
in the buddy system they stopped and got
food they ubered home they let their dog
out to go potty and then they locked
their house up and this still happened
the University of Idaho president was
also at that press conference yesterday
and said he's asking professors to
prepare two options in person and remote
learning because he recognizes some
students might not want to come back to
campus with this killer on the loose but
others might want the comfort of their
friends Nate
Christina thank you so much it's so hard
Nate to see the video of the girls as
you as you since we know how that story
ended and it's so hard to believe that
it will take very long to solve this
case yeah I mean you know there's a
keypad that you have to get in there so
many questions yeah a lot of questions
but they cleared the person that drove
them home yeah the other people in the
house in the house yeah so I also think
police know far more than they're
telling us as it should be that might be
part of the investigation as it should
be